il a rebranché françoise hardy il a
métamorphosé france gall et il a revampé
johnny hallyday sans pour autant me plus
préoccupé de lui même voici michel
berger
michel bienvenu son plateau de soupe à
la une alors comme tag de philo et puis
que tu as un look en acier robotique
avait choisi bien enseigner dans le rôle
de cheveux oui j'étais préparé un
questionnaire de proust rajeuni tu très
très mauvais pour s'acheter prévient
parce que il faut toujours répondre des
choses très drôle répond des choses très
profondes
bon il faut du temps alors là alors
première question quel est pour toi le
comble de la misère à voilà j'y
répondrai au premier degré je crois que
c'est c'est petit enfants qui meurent de
faim parce qu'on a vu les images de
d'enfants en train de mourir de faim
depuis depuis quelques mois la télé ça
c'est vraiment chaud de très très
pénibles
quel est ton idéal de bonheur terrestre
alors là si je dirais blonde 1 m 65 les
yeux marrons tu vois jean pop star dont
metteur en scène de cinéma favori je
dirais qu bois et que je serai bien
petite commune et musical passionnant
ton père favorisant ton pot est favori
je suis pas prévert desnos on décide ce
qui est écrit dans ce genre de choses
c'est qu'on oblige un homme ça c'est
terrible
est-ce que tu serais capable de tuer
quelqu'un ça coûterait très cher
non merci pas il fallait que j'essaye
pour voir tout serait capable fruits tu
me regardes tu aurais tu aimé être
c'était tout à michel berger j'aurais
bien et emmitt carl lewis par exemple
doit ces sites qui est il autant du
monde de 100 m 200 m mcenroe un grand
sportif que détestent le tue par dessus
tout fait pour éviter les questions que
ce sont avant tout réfléchir quoique lui
à la survie de l'âme donc ça tu vois ça
voilà qui pique le genre de guy noves
que paris pendant deux ans
si tu veux on fait un dossier de l'écran
fait l'émission grand échiquier déjà
voilà c'est une très bonne question pour
le signer comment es tu aimerais tu
mourir
ok n'offre en train de faire de la
musique
quel est ton état d'esprit paix le calme
nerveux voix très très ambitieux très
serein très bien manger merci beaucoup